monsieur le député Caron avec le sens de
la nuance qui vous est mondialement
reconnu vous me posez une question sur
le S métola clore alors d'abord on va
vous redonner les objectifs du
gouvernement ceux qui sont ceux de la
première ministre qui sont ceux du
ministre de la Santé qui sont ceux du
ministre de la transition écologique et
qui sont ceux du ministre de la culture
c'est la réduction de l'usage des
produits phytosanitaires première
élément de la stratégie et je dis
d'ailleurs qu'une partie du chemin a été
fait puisque sur les molécules classées
dite CM1 on a déjà réduit de 80 à 85%
les usages et donc vous devriez regarder
les choses avec ce regard là le deuxième
sujet c'est d'agir en européen il est
inutile et on ne peut pas passer son
temps et compris dans cette assemblée à
parler de surtransposition et quand il y
a des sujets de sans transposition ne
pas essayer de les poser sur la table
troisième sujet c'est d'essayer de
construire des alternatives alors je
sais que vous pensez que les
interdictions produisent des solutions
mais moi je pense qu'on a besoin tandis
qu'on a des interrogations sur des
molécules de construire ensemble des
alternatives et des solutions ne vous en
déplaisent on a besoin aussi de
travailler avec la recherche avec la
science sur ces éléments là alors quel
crime ai-je commis ce Caron j'ai
interrogé simplement non pas la décision
personne ne me trouvera sur le chemin de
remettre en cause contrairement à vous
d'ailleurs parfois les décisions les
avis de lancest j'ai simplement
interrogé compte tenu d'un calendrier
européen qui évoluait s'il n'y avait pas
lieu de se conformer un calendrier
européen même nature par souci pardon
simplement de cohérence alors je sais
que vous avez du mal avec ces éléments
là vous avez du mal avec ces éléments là
et donc j'ai simplement posé cette
question sans remettre du tout en cause
lisez les courriers monsieur Caron sans
remettre du tout en cause la décision
l'ancêtre simplement comme on était dans
une non sans comme on était dans une
cohérence de calendrier je me demandais
simplement s'il y avait pas lieu
d'interroger cette question sous cette
hommage d'ailleurs je signale que
l'anxess donne un certain nombre de mois
pour sortir de cette molécule c'est dire
si cette question du calendrier peut
être mise au débat puisque c'est une
question qui est posée par la tête alors
je sais Monsieur Caron vous avez du mal
à poser à vous poser des questions quand
vous posez des questions et à nourrir
des querelles autre que celle que vous
nouez en tout cas nous on avance mais
cette trajectoire de réduction des
titres sanitaires merci